So, da bin ich wieder. Wir probieren heute mal was aus, gucken ob das taugt und gucken, ob das ohne irgendwie
Appstore-Registrierung oder hast du nicht gesehen funktioniert. Ich habe noch keine große Ahnung, ich habe nur vorhin gesehen,
dass die ein
öffentlich verfügbares SDK haben
für Garmin-Uhren und also für die Garmin-Fitness-Uhren und für die Fahrradcomputer und sowas
Und ich habe, ich habe letztens, ich bin ja vorgestern
Nee, nicht vorgestern, gestern eine Runde Fahrrad gefahren und ich habe mir gedacht, so eine Sache wäre cool und dann gucken wir mal, ob ich
so etwas selbst programmieren kann.
Mal schauen, wie das funktioniert, ich bin mal gespannt.
Mon cas.
Wir machen schon mal die VM an, bis Twitch richtig gecheckt hat, dass der Stream online ist.
Aktuell, neun Leute, da hat Twitch auf jeden Fall noch keine Notifications geschickt.
Wir machen mal den Stream an, Arch by the way, erstmal noch eine Package-Update
und dann gucken wir mal.
CBDEV, moin. Ich glaube, jetzt hat Twitch kapiert, dass der Stream online ist.
Kernel-Update dabei, mega.
Dann können wir es so lassen.
Moment, das muss ein bisschen
advancer sein.
Was wir machen, ist folgendes, zumindest was wir probieren werden, ist folgendes, guckt mal.
Nehmt mal
Bei deinem Kinderarzt lief Asquiquarium. Ernsthaft?
Also, nehmt mal beispielsweise so einen Garmin-Fahrradcomputer hier als Beispiel.
Da gibt es ja
solche
Also die Bilder davon sehen nicht so aus wie in der Realität.
Jetzt noch
Datafield
Ja doch, da oben, hier sieht man es ganz gut. Also guckt mal, Leute.
Es gibt auf Garmin-Uhren und generell auf Garmin-Geräten
gibt es solche customizable
Layouts, wo man Datafields reinpacken kann.
Und diese Datafields kann man mit dem Garmin-SDK selbst entwickeln, beziehungsweise man kann auch komplette Apps für das Ding entwickeln.
Und das will ich mal ausprobieren, weil
Ich zeige euch auch mal warum
Nicht
wirklich
Ja, so ungefähr. Das ist eigentlich ein ganz gutes Beispiel, guckt mal. Also, wenn du die Navigationsfunktion
benutzt
Dann hat man, okay, man hat hier eine Anzeige für den Berg, das
Das hat man nicht immer, weil man sieht man von der Karte nichts, aber Garmin erlaubt hier unten
nur zwei
customizable Datafields und das ist ein bisschen wenig. Ja, also ich hätte schon ganz gerne, auch wenn ich die Karte auf habe, hätte ich sowas wie
Geschwindigkeit, Herzfrequenz und die Herzfrequenz muss ich gar nicht haben. Es reicht mir eine Anzeige mit der Farbe
Oder eben halt auch einen Timer oder irgendwie sowas. Also mehr als zwei Datafields da unten wäre schon ganz cool.
So, und was ich mir gedacht habe, was wir ausprobieren können, ich habe keine Ahnung ob das ob und wie das funktioniert,
wir können ein großes Custom-Datafield bauen,
was wiederum klein die anderen Daten in etwas kleiner anzeigen kann. Dass das prinzipiell
funktioniert, habe ich schon gesehen im Garmin-Store, dass es da sowas gibt, aber ich habe mir gedacht
man kann ja mal probieren das selbst zu bauen. Welche Smartwatch, also ich habe eine Forerunner
255, auf der kann man das auch ausprobieren, aber mir geht es hauptsächlich um den Fahrradcomputer als für Datafield, aber auf der Uhr geht es genauso.
Letztendlich ist aber auch egal, weil das funktioniert auf beiden Geräten, hoffe ich mal zumindest. Wie gesagt, ich will ein Datafield machen, was in klein
mehrere Datafields anzeigen kann. Das wäre natürlich sehr praktisch, vielleicht ein bisschen schlecht lesbar,
aber auf jeden Fall besser, als die Informationen gar nicht drauf haben. Also aktuell
Android? Nein, nicht Android. Wie kommst du auf Android?
Das läuft auf den Garmin-Geräten, das ist irgendein Embedded-Zeug, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, man muss das sogar in C++ programmieren, das wird was.
Komm, wir machen mal ein bisschen was anderes.
Epic Chillstep Collection. Was machen wir denn? Komm, ein bisschen wupp wupp.
Also das Garmin-Zeug, könnte ich wetten, ist kein Android.
Das ist so customizable und
das wirkt so low-level, dass ich, ich könnte wetten, dass es nicht Android wird,
dass es irgendwas Spezielles von Garmin. Was auch dazu passen würde...
Äh, äh, äh, äh.
Wo kommt die Musik her? Keck Wade, Alter.
Das würde auch widersprechen, dass es Android wäre, weil das irgendeine Custom
Garmin-SDK braucht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie advanced die sind, ob die einen Device Emulator haben, ob ich dann meine Uhr per USB anschließen muss oder den
Fahrradkomputer. Beides hier liegen,
glaube ich, ja, beides hier liegen, ne die Uhr nicht, aber den Fahrradkomputer hier liegen, um das auszuprobieren.
Ich bin mal, ich bin mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert. Also mein Ziel ist es ein Custom Data Field zu bauen, ähnlich zu dem hier.
Warte mal, ich habe nämlich sowas gefunden und das war eine super, super nice, äh,
super nice Idee, aber mit der Umsetzung bin ich nicht ganz zufrieden. Also ich will sowas ähnliches bauen.
Kann man das hier nicht nach Trending oder sowas sortieren?
Warum ist die, warum ist die Web, die Web-Ausgabe für diesen Shop so,
so kacke?
Also ich würde gerne was installieren, also ich würde gerne was machen, ähnlich
zu dem da. Genau, hier, das ist ein gutes Beispiel. Guck mal, der Dude hat genau das Gleiche gebaut.
Das hier unten ist ein Custom Data Field, also wenn ihr das hier seht, der hat einfach ein großes Feld gemacht, wo er selbst
in kleinen Sachen anzeigen lassen kann. Sowas in der Richtung
will ich auch bauen, nur, dass ich nicht so viele Sachen anzeigen möchte und einfach, mich interessiert auch einfach, wie das funktioniert, ja.
Nur, dass ich nicht so viele Sachen anzeigen will,
weil die werden zu klein. Ich habe das von, ich habe das Data Field von dem hier mal ausprobiert, das ist mini.
Du kannst kaum was erkennen, wenn du normal auf dem Fahrrad drauf sitzt.
Dafür passten hier sechs Felder hin, anstatt wie offiziell bei Garmin nur zwei.
Also ist schon, ist schon eine coole Sache und ich wollte mir das immer angucken, wie das funktioniert.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Nein, das ist, ich bin mir jetzt, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es nicht Android wie es ist.
Aber das ist, das ist da way, nee, das ist das Ziel heute. Kann man auf dem Computer, Fahrradcomputer Docker laufen lassen? Nee.
Ich gehe mal ganz stark davon aus, dass es auch noch nicht mal auf Linux Basis ist, sondern irgendein Embedded Ding.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, auf was die Garmin Sachen basieren.
Guck mal, ob man irgendwie was weiß. What's the CPU? Ja, zeigt doch mal her.
Custom Socks, okay. Also, man hat keine Ahnung, man hat, okay, man hat keine Ahnung, was, was in den,
was in den Dingern drin ist.
Was in den Dingern drin ist, ist ja, man hat, man hat keine Ahnung. Nicht Firerunner. Also, man, okay.
Irgendein Qualcomm irgendwas.
Teardown.
Okay, von 2016.
Das bringt nix.
Benchmark Results.
Wie die machen Benchmarks auf ihrer Uhr?
Schraub mal auf. Nee, nee, nee.
Also, man hat, man hat, glaube ich, echt keine Ahnung, was da drin ist. Ach, hier.
Armkiste.
Zumindest, zumindest in, in, in der Phoenix Uhr.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da gescheit Android draufläuft.
Also, keine Ahnung, was da drauf ist.
Letztendlich ist es aber auch vollkommen egal, was da drauf ist, weil wir werden das offizielle SDK von denen verwenden.
Also,
das könnte ich mir, Moment, Moment, Moment, das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es das sogar gibt.
Ohne Scheiß, Doom gibt es, gibt es überall.
Wartet mal, Doom.
Wobei, Moment, das ist nicht Doom. Das ist, glaube ich, einfach, ach, das ist nur, nee, okay, es ist gar nicht Doom.
Es ist einfach nur die Zahlen, das Font, der Doom Font.
Aber, ey, mich hätt's wirklich nicht gewundert, wenn,
wär vorbei, keine Ahnung. Also, mich hätt es wirklich nicht, nee, nee, nee, ist nicht, mich hätt es wirklich nicht gewundert, wenn es Doom auf der Uhr gibt.
Also, möglich, möglich wäre das wahrscheinlich.
Ich meine, Doom läuft auf dem Schwangerschaftstest, wobei, das war nur Fake, aber trotzdem.
Also, mich würde es echt nicht wundern, wenn da irgendeiner Doom zum Laufen bekommt auf der Uhr.
Garmin Watch Doom.
Siehste, siehste, es gibt schon Leute.
Data Field von Garmin.
Ach, nee, nee, okay.
Naja, also,
also, das würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es das gibt. Durchaus, durchaus möglich, dass irgendwelche verrückten Leute auf ihrer Garmin Uhr
es laufen lassen haben.
So, also, probieren wir das mal aus. Es gibt irgendwo ein offizielles Garmin SDK.
Ich mache mal einen Snapshot.
Nee, das kriege ich nicht hin. Ich mache mal einen Snapshot von meiner 4M. Warum habe ich da so viele Snapshots gerade?
Ah, nice, Snapshot 2 und 3, aber Snapshot 1 gibt es nicht.
Warum genau habe ich hier nochmal gesnapshotet?
Ach so, wegen Mojo-Installationen, ich glaube.
So, machen wir das mal weg. Snapshots verbrauchen, gerade umso älter sie werden, umso größer das Diff wird,
verbrauchen Snapshots immer unsinnig viel Speicherplatz.
Auf, geh weg. Siehste, ist schon ein bisschen größer, der Snapshot.
Snapschut, forever.
Also, let's go.
Erstmal das SDK runterladen. Get the connect IQ. Siehste, die wissen schon mal Bescheid. Only five header.
Hey Max, Moment, was? Hey Max, bin seit 1.9., das ist quasi seit einem Monat.
Bog.
In der Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung. Wollte mich bedanken, dass du mich dafür begeistern kannst mit Instruments.
Ja, das ist nice. Ich hoffe, dir gefällt's. Wie war so der erste Monat?
Schau deinen Plan, was deine App können soll. Ja, ich habe das ja gerade eben gezeigt.
Ich will sowas hier in der Richtung bauen, also nicht mit der Map und so.
Also, es gibt auf den Fahrradcomputern, auf den Uhren gibt es so customizable data fields.
Und gerade, was mich, was mich ein bisschen nervt, ist auf der Map-Übersicht kann man nur zwei data fields einblenden.
Und ich wollte sowas ähnliches bauen, wie der Dude hier.
Der quasi ein Custom-Data-Feld gebaut hat, in dem er selbst wiederum kleinere data fields anzeigt, sodass quasi
anstatt, anstatt zwei in diesen Space hier,
dann sechs Stück passen. Nur, dass mir das hier so nicht gefällt, weil es doch sehr klein und pixelige Schrift ist.
Mir würden ja drei Stück reichen, ja, oder, oder sagen wir mal vielleicht vier, da hat man ein bisschen mehr Platz.
Und außerdem interessiert mich einfach nur,
wie das funktioniert.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass wir heute da wirklich was Sinnvolles auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ich muss erst mal das Garmin-SDK runterladen und dann, guck mal hier, also, da steht auch, wie das funktioniert hier.
Install-SDK.
Launch-SDK-Manager, bla bla bla. Installing... Moment, was? Monkey-C.
Haben die einen eigenen C-Dialekt, um den Kram zu programmieren? Was zum Teufel ist Monkey-C?
Ich meine, Holy-C würde ich ja noch verstehen. Okay, hat mit C anscheinend gar nichts zu tun. Das Buch ist ja äußerst beliebt.
Nein, Poggers Buch.
Okay, download and accept for Linux. Das ging aber schnell. 3,2 MB, das ist, das ist
Blazingly-Fast-Embedded-Kram.
Äh, nicht Repos. Downloads.
Garmin, Pog. So, da wurde es entpackt. Und was muss man jetzt machen?
Launch-SDK-Manager vom chosen download location, also wahrscheinlich das hier, SDK.
Okay, was? Webkit-GTK. What?
Ernsthaft?
Okay, Webkit-GTK.
Im Prinzip, im Prinzip ist es wahrscheinlich wirklich nur, sie hätten es auch Elektron machen können, oder?
Ja.
Okay, Leute,
acceptet ihr auch die Terms of Service?
Also, ich finde die Terms of Service sind schon sehr nice.
Och nee.
Alter.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ja, das ist schon mal scheiße. Wie soll ich?
Ich vermute mal, hier ist ein User-Feld, hier ist ein, hier ist ein
Passwort-Feld und hier ist ein, ja, das ist, okay, das, okay, Leute, es könnte, es könnte schon mal scheitern
an ganz grundlegenden Sachen. Webkit-GTK.
Kann ich vielleicht noch anderes installieren? Was ist das? 4, 2, 2, 4, 2, 2,
4, 11, Legacy, Legacy. Wobei, nee, wir brauchen Webkit-GTK 2.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist, das habe ich eben installiert. Also, mein GTK-Theme ist eigentlich legit
NWG-Look. Okay, ich ändere mal mein, mein Theme.
Machen wir das, wir machen das Default-Theme.
Guck mal hier, Icons und Icons. Wir machen, wir machen mal das Default-Theme hier.
Okay.
Als, als Flatpak-User ausführen, was? Gibt es das als Flatpak? Okay, das funktioniert nicht.
Das geht schon, das geht schon gut los. Das ist weiße Schrift auf weißem Hintergrund. Ja, würde ich auch so sehen.
Ähm, Leute, ich, ich sehe irgendwie, dass das nichts wird.
Also,
Okay, Moment, Moment. Webkit-GTK-White. Wie sucht man danach? White Text und White Background, alles klar.
Okay, aha, was?
Was zum Teufel interessiert mich Evolution? Das, das, das, das, das,
das ist das E-Mail-Programm.
Okay, das ist wohl ein, ein Known-Bug oder sowas. Fixed. Nee, es ist Fixed.
Okay, ich habe eine, ich habe eine Idee, was wir machen. Ich habe, ich habe eine Idee, was wir machen.
Webkit-GTK, wir uninstallen das nochmal.
Und jetzt,
das hatten wir gerade installiert, ne? Nee, das ist immer noch installiert.
Hä?
Okay, Webkit-GTK. Was, was hat ich eben installiert? Das hier. Das hier hatte ich installiert.
Dann installieren wir doch einfach mal das hier. Vielleicht funktioniert das, funktioniert das aus irgendwelchen Gründen besser.
Warum hat das vor allem die gleiche Versionsnummer?
Ich hatte alle drei installiert, wirklich?
Ach, Moment, wir brauchen auch noch das Vierer.
Ach, shit.
Äh, Gott.
Geht schon, es geht, es geht schon, es geht schon gut los. Dann installiere ich jetzt einfach das da aus dem, aus dem, aua.
Oje, wenn man, wenn man ein Webkit, wenn man ein Webkit selbst kompilieren muss, das dauert auch bestimmt jetzt drei Stunden, oder?
Schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal. Ich, ich weiß nicht, wie schnell man ein Webkit selbst kompilieren kann. Und
Ja, das ist aber eine VM und Browser kompilieren dauert immer drei, dreieinhalb Stunden, weil vielleicht geht das, vielleicht geht das ja hier gerade. Schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal.
Es ist ja gar nicht gesagt, dass es danach tut. Lass uns lieber noch mal kurz googeln, was das Problem, äh, Problem ist.
White background.
Wir suchen einfach nach GTK, no content.
Ja, nice.
Ja, angeblich wurde das ja gefixt, ne?
Das bringt mir nur jetzt nicht allzu viel.
Kann man irgendwie disable Hardware Acceleration oder so?
Vielleicht, vielleicht liegt das daran, dass der irgendwie komisch rendert?
Web, okay, was? Webkit Force, okay, mein was?
Webkit, Webkit Force Composition Mode.
Force Accelerated Composition Mode.
Force Accelerated Compose to be always on, to be always off.
Jetzt das, oh, das wird gebastelt, Leute, ich sag's euch.
Okay, Webkit kompilieren läuft.
Die, die volle, die volle Open-Source-Linux-Developer-Experience heute.
Also ich geb dir mal fünf Minuten Zeit.
Wenn dann der nicht fertig ist, dann lasse ich's bleiben und installiere das andere wieder.
Und wir probieren mal die Environment Variables aus.
Ob die, ob die was machen?
Ach so, wie sieht's eigentlich aus?
Hessen, Wahl 2023, Hochrechnungen.
Mal gucken, ob der Markt das regelt oder nicht.
Äh, Ergebnisse.
Okay, CDU 35%, wir hatten Vergleich zum letzten Mal vielleicht.
Okay, grüne minus SPD, grüne CDU massig plus, AfD plus, FDP minus.
Oh nein, der Markt regelt doch nicht.
Ich hoffe, der Markt regelt noch.
Zumindest über 5%.
Oh, was jetzt? Das wollte ich nicht.
Ja, zum Glück, ne? Vielleicht hängt's an meiner Stimme am Ende.
Dass es wird oder nicht.
Was ist schlimmer, Garmin, Monkeysee oder Mon-
Weiß ich nicht, ich konnte bis jetzt beides ja nicht ausprobieren.
Atheno, Dankeschön für den Sub, hab ich komplett übersehen?
Sorry, falls ich irgendwie noch jemanden übersehen hab, aber ich glaub nicht.
Stimmt, wie sieht's in Bayern aus?
Bayern, Wahl 2023, Hochrechnungen.
Die CSU liegt vorne, ja das ist Bayern, da liegt die CSU immer vorne.
Das geht gar nicht, das ist petty false so.
Okay, um 19.06 gab's CDU, äh, nein, CSU ist es ja in Bayern.
36%, ach, der Markt regelt nicht in Bayern.
Die AfD, einfach mal die Hälfte fast von der CSU.
Okay, die komische Bayern-Partei ist nicht am Start.
Und die Freien Wähler gehen auch gut ab, immerhin Bayern.
Wie sieht denn die Regierung aktuell in Bayern aus?
Ist das CSU und Freie Wähler?
Ich glaub schon, oder?
Keine Ahnung, was in Bayern abgeht.
Hessen interessiert mich mehr.
Boah, ey, ich hab keinen Bock, Webkit beim Kompilieren zuzugucken.
Das geht auch so langsam.
Wenn ich das jetzt abbreche, hab ich so ein halbkompiliertes Webkit auf der Platte.
Wobei das nicht schlimm ist, ich hab ja einen Snapshot gemacht.
Okay, ich lass das da oben mal kurz kompilieren, das stört ja nicht großartig.
Installieren wir nochmal Webkit-GTK.
Das da brauchen wir.
So wie es aussieht.
Fünf brauchen wir, ne?
Webkit-GTK.
So, und jetzt setzen wir, was war das?
Webkit-Disable-Composition-Mode.
Auf 1, nicht auf True, auf 1.
Wobei das eigentlich aufs Gleiche rauskommen sollte.
Bin.
Garmin.
What?
Hab ich doch gerade installiert.
Das muss ich auch noch installieren.
Ich mag ja nicht.
Fuck.
Ah, ah.
Easy.
Fixed.
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
So, da können wir das komische Webkit-Kompilierungszeug hier oben abbrechen.
Okay, also jetzt brauch ich ein Webkit-Account.
Nein, kein Webkit-Account.
Nein, ich habe kein Account.
Kann ich das nicht im Browser irgendwie machen?
Garmin-Developer-Account.
Wir machen wieder ein Fake.
Garmin-Developer.
Okay, wo erstelle ich mir hier ein Account?
Account.
Developer-Forum.
Äh.
Ja, Developer-Programm.
Okay, das ist super kompliziert, schon mal das Richtige zu finden.
Account.
Muss man das über die komische App, muss man das wirklich hier drüber machen?
Okay, create a new account.
Okay, also.
Ich habe die Terms, ich habe die Terms gelesen und kriege.
Max.
Wupp.
E-Mail-Adresse, okay.
10-Minute-Mail.
Beste E-Mail-Adresse überhaupt, die will ich haben.
Oh, man darf da nicht...
Copy-Pasten, man, ist das nervig.
Z-Bock.
Passwort, okay.
Ähm.
Nur kurz aufschreiben.
So.
Germany, create account.
Ach, man muss doch nicht mal bestätigen.
Na, umso besser.
Man muss doch nicht mal bestätigen, das ist gut.
So.
Logged in as Max Wupp.
Next.
Automatic Updates, Automatic Downloads, Automatic Updates, jawoll.
Ähm.
Watches, Bikes, Wearables, alles.
New devices are being downloaded.
Alles, okay.
Dann, dann fetcht mal.
Yes.
Okay, das ist ja gar nicht so schlecht gemacht.
Kriege ich erstmal 300 Emulatoren installiert, okay.
Oh, im Hintergrund geht da schon mal gut was ab.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich brauche gar nicht die tausend Sachen und Devices.
Aber gut, wir lassen ihn mal, wir lassen ihn mal kurz, wir lassen ihn mal kurz machen.
Ähm.
Also.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Ich glaube, das kann man auch gar nicht abbrechen.
Ich glaube, wir müssen den jetzt mal kurz zwei Minuten in Ruhe lassen.
Und, und den Kram installieren.
Weiß ja nicht wirklich, was der gerade da im Hintergrund treibt.
Also, wenn das in dem Tempo weitergeht, dann sitzen wir morgen noch.
Gucken, ob das überhaupt irgendwas macht im Hintergrund.
Sieht jetzt für mich nämlich nicht so aus.
Öh.
Okay, dann ist es noch am Downloaden.
Und dann dauert es wahrscheinlich nur wegen dem Download ein bisschen.
Ey, das liegt, das liegt am Download.
Gehe ich mal von aus.
Das wird wahrscheinlich unterschiedlich groß sein und der Download nicht so schnell.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es alles dann mehr oder weniger zeitgleich, zeitgleich fertig wird.
Ich meine, es wäre ja auch ganz sinnvoll.
Wir machen einfach mal nur bei Computer.
Aber dann bricht er trotzdem nicht ab.
Ich schaue mal, ob ich das beschleunigen kann, wenn ich quitte.
Und nochmal starte.
Was?
Oh, ist das schlecht, Alter.
Was habe ich für eine E-Mail-Adresse?
Okay, Z-Bock.
Okay, immerhin.
Guck mal.
Er downloadet jetzt tatsächlich nur noch das, was ich, was ich haben will.
Okay, man musste.
Das wirkt aber, das wirkt aber nicht so gut.
Das wirkt aber, das wirkt aber ziemlich fragil, was sie da gebaut haben.
Hast du geschaut, ob es eine Bestätigungs-E-Mail gibt?
Nö.
Mit sowas geben die sich das gar nicht ab.
Wer braucht schon Bestätigungs-E-Mails?
Okay, das scheint ein bisschen schneller zu gehen.
So, wie geht's, wie geht's denn dann weiter?
So, als erstes getten wir das Garmin SDK.
Complete first time setup process.
Download latest connect IQ SDK.
Download completes.
Klick yes.
Klick der SDK.
Close der SDK Manager.
Okay, wir können ja schon mal den nächsten Schritt machen.
In Visual Studio Code.
Go to Extensions.
Monkeysy, Alter.
Was wird es schon wieder, dass ich hier alles geben muss?
Könnten die, können die nicht?
Also, könnten die nicht irgendeine normale Programmiersprache nehmen?
Javascript, Python, sonst was?
Warum muss es monkeysy sein?
Nice, ffmpeg, hi-res, gif.
Okay, wir installieren die monkeysy-Extension.
Gut, gut, dass ich den Snapshot gemacht habe.
Moment, es gibt zwei Sachen.
Es gibt das.
Das ist das Offizielle von Garmin.
Und das hier ist von Alexander Fedora.
Changelog ohne Datum ist auch immer geil.
Hier, 2020.
Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall das Simmigere.
Okay, wir sind fertig.
Close.
Das ist der Cousin von, der Cousin vor allem.
Btop ist zu fancy.
Select Install Button.
Ja, ja, ja.
Restart Visual Studio Code.
Okay.
After, Restart.
Summon the Command Plate.
Verify Installation and select.
Verify Installation.
Okay, Cousin.
Cousin ist dumm, der macht das.
Genau.
Verify Installation.
Generate Developer Key.
Was mache ich gerade?
Downloads.
Garmin POG.
Haben wir mal hier einen Ordner.
Irgendwie Projects oder so, keine Ahnung.
Open.
Ja.
Java.
Okay.
Open JDK.
Was ist denn da der Default mittlerweile?
Was installiert man denn, wenn man Java installieren will?
Was sind das hier?
Open JDK 19.
21.
Was haben die da zusammengeschustert?
Ja, das frage ich mich auch gerade.
Das frage ich mich auch.
Okay, nochmal Visual Studio Code starten.
Verify Installation.
Okay, Monkey See Installation verified.
Ganz toll und jetzt?
Get the Connect IQ Mobile SDK.
Nee.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Und, und, und jetzt?
Und.
Ich meine.
Der Guide ist etwas incomplete, oder?
Das SDK ist auch ein geiles SDK.
Es hat einfach keine Beispiele oder sonst irgendwas dabei.
Okay, wir gehen erstmal hier in Projects und öffnen Visual Studio Code da.
Ja, ja, wir trusten.
Oh, guck mal, da ist mein Developer Key.
Den sollte ich vielleicht nicht leaken.
Also machen wir hier Projects 2.
Was ist da?
Okay, Visual Studio Code.
Ich truste.
Okay, wie geht das jetzt?
Monkey.
Monkey See.
Okay.
Clean Projects.
Launch new Project.
Set Project Name.
Kackel.
Data Field. Widget.
Watch App.
Okay, Leute, ich würde sagen, wir tun erstmal so, weil ich glaube, da kommt man am besten damit rein.
Als würden wir eine Watch App programmieren.
Weil ich hoffe, da ist so eine Art Simulator oder sowas dabei.
Alternativ können wir auch einen Monkey Barrel entwickeln.
Was auch immer das ist.
Vielleicht einen fancy Namen für ein Package.
Watch Face.
Wir tun mal so, als wollen wir eine Application.
Ich will eigentlich gar keine App, sondern ein Data Field bauen.
Minimum.
Ne, immer beste, neueste, geilste API.
Select the products to support.
Edge 840.
Project 2. Ganz toll.
Nice.
Gibt es Hello World oder so?
MC.
MC. Kackel App MC.
Uiuiui.
Es hat ein bisschen was von Dart, oder?
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Ein bisschen.
Moment, haben wir Autocomplete?
Ui, ja.
Uiuiui.
Massive.
Gibt es sowas?
Es muss ja irgendwie ein Run oder sowas.
Run.
Launch.
Configure Monkey Barrel.
What?
Build.
Build current project.
No device available.
Ich habe doch Edge runtergeladen.
Äh.
Monkeys.
SDK Manager.
Ja, da ist er.
Wie oft muss ich das noch machen?
Meine E-Mail Adresse.
Sekunde.
Oh, fuck.
Ähm.
Chat, hat jemand aufgepasst?
Z-Bock irgendwas?
Ah, da ist sie hier.
Z-Bock.
Muss ich mir auch mal aufschreiben.
Wie oft muss ich das noch machen?
Okay, finish.
Habe ich doch hier, guck mal.
Und was haben wir jetzt hier?
Manifests.
Was ist ein Data Field?
Sowas hier.
Eines dieser Kästchen hier unten.
Sollte ich den vielleicht im Hintergrund
mal die Uhren runterladen lassen?
Also eine zumindest.
Hier, Forerunner 255.
Habe ich.
Ich habe ein Watch.
Ich habe ein App-Projekt erstellt.
Das ist glaube ich nicht,
dass sie einen Unterschied machen
zwischen
Resources.
Manifests.
Warum haben wir hier zweimal Keckel?
Wir haben Projects Keckel.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Warum haben wir das hier doppelt offen?
Ich schaue mal kurz zu.
Das ist komisch.
Monkey Jungle.
Boah, ich raste aus.
Können die nicht irgendwas
benutzen, was jeder versteht?
Da stand Watch UI.
Ich denke mal, das heißt halt einfach so.
Okay, was haben wir hier?
Use the following from
Visual Studio Code Command Palette
to edit Build Targets.
Set Product.
Touch by Computers.
Ach, einfach alles.
Okay, easy.
So, zack.
Jetzt haben wir alle Support.
Build Current Project
für Edge.
Easy.
Jetzt ist nur die Frage, wie man das
in irgendeinem Simulator starten kann.
Ich habe gesehen,
dass sie sowas haben.
Launch Complication.
Compilation?
Complication?
What?
Was wird hier?
Was wird hier gelaunched?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Okay, Build for Devices.
Hammer gemacht.
Edit Application.
Edit Export Project.
Open.
Wieso heißt das Ding Monkey Sea
und warum brauchst du Java?
Ich musste Garmin fragen.
Okay, wir müssen uns die Hilfe-Seite mal abchecken.
Okay.
Connect IQ Basics.
Your First App.
Das ist Eclipse.
Okay, New.
Select Project Watch Face.
Okay, Select Simple Template.
Select Minimum RP.
Run.
Run the Program.
Okay, wie geht das?
Select Run Without Debugging.
Run.
Run Without Debugging.
Oh!
Es runnt!
Kacke.
Easy.
Ey!
Komm mal an!
Der Device Emulator.
Emulated.
Oh, was hast du?
Datafields, Layout, Invalid.
HDB Connection.
Ja, nee, bestimmt nicht.
Okay.
Ich habe einen Garmin-Uhr und einen Fahrradcomputer.
Ich finde die Dinger nice.
Activity Data.
Vibrate, Sleep Mode.
Okay, also wie habe ich das jetzt gemacht?
Run Without Debugging.
Also Ctrl F5.
Hat das Hot Reload?
Leute, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Hat das so eine Art Hot Reload?
Ähm.
Äh.
Wie kann ich das jetzt ausprobieren?
Resources, Strings.
App Name, Kacke.
Kacke W heißt die App jetzt.
Nee.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
Okay, das hat es nicht.
Das hat es nicht gecheckt.
Vielleicht muss ich erst Bild machen.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht, Leute.
Das hätte ich mir jetzt schlimmer vorgestellt.
Was ist denn der Knopf da unten?
Data Playback.
Backlight.
Das ist doch gar nicht so kacke.
Das geht doch voll klar.
Gut.
Dann kann ich tatsächlich nochmal ein neues Projekt machen,
nachdem ich jetzt weiß, wie das funktioniert.
Ups.
Das hätte ich gar nicht schließen müssen.
New Project, Monkey C.
Und zwar.
Ähm.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Datafield nenne ich es einfach mal.
Ich will ein Datafield entwickeln.
Äh, Datafield.
That extends the simple Datafield class.
A Datafield,
that extends the Datafield class.
Okay.
Wir machen erst mal simple.
Select minimum supported API.
Ja.
Ich meine, ich habe eh die neueste Version, so Edge.
Äh.
Und wohin? Hier rein.
Ja.
Wollen wir das nochmal schließen.
Nach Datafield.
What?
Hä?
Warte mal, ich bin verwirrt.
Habe ich das jetzt da rein erstellt oder wie?
Ah ja.
Datafield eins nach oben.
Datafield.
Und jetzt Visual Studio Code hier drinnen öffnen.
Das da down save.
Zack.
Nice.
So, das sieht jetzt deutlich,
deutlich weniger aus.
Schauen wir mal, Build.
Current Project.
Und jetzt.
Ne, was, wie war das? Run?
Run without debugging.
Monkey See.
Bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Hey, das funst.
Das, das funst.
Datafields layout.
Ja.
Also so würde das dann, also
eins davon wäre halt nur mein Datafield
und realistisch, realistisch betrachtet
will ich eigentlich
vier mal vier,
weil ich ein breites,
ich will ein Datafield machen,
was ein zweier Datafield ausnutzt.
Wobei eher, eher
in der Größe würde ich sagen,
das ist realistischer.
Ja, das funktioniert doch gar nicht
mal so mies.
Ganz gut, klar.
So, also mein Datafield
muss gut aussehen
in dieser,
in dieser Größe,
weil mein Datafield soll
hier unterhalb von der Map
angezeigt werden können.
Also Chat, was sagt ihr?
Ich finde, das ist gar nicht mal
schlecht, wie die das bis jetzt
gemacht haben.
Ich finde, ich finde, das geht,
das geht echt klar.
Das können wir noch ein bisschen
kleiner machen hier, so.
Ich, ich, ich finde das,
ich finde das geht voll klar.
Ja, so soll mein Datafield
später aussehen.
Genauso ein breites hier,
wie das da.
Ja, wir haben auch schon
schlimmeres gesehen.
Wie funktioniert das?
Also wir haben jetzt, wir haben jetzt
ja bisher nur das Ganze eingerichtet.
Wie, wie, wie,
wie programmiert man den Kram?
Okay, Datafield App
Extends Application Base.
Datafield View.
Jetzt schauen wir mal, wie gut,
wie gut die, die
Autocompletion ist.
Simple Data.
Okay, sie funktioniert schon mal.
Noch, noch besser als
das Rust Plugin noch vor kurzer Zeit.
Ich habe natürlich absolut
keine Ahnung von der API.
So, woher, woher kommt das überhaupt,
dass es ein Label gibt?
Label, woher weiß ich denn,
Hat vielleicht, hat vielleicht
das, vielleicht ist das ein Base.
Base? Gibt es sowas wie Base
oder This oder so?
Vielleicht, vielleicht kommt
das ja vom, vom Simple Data Field.
Okay, Jump, Jump 2 gibt es
schon mal nicht.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt mal
in die API-Docs reingucken.
Zeig mal kurz, was in Hessen so abgeht.
Hochrechnung in Hessen 1924.
Die CDU geht übelst ab.
Der Markt regelt immer noch
bei 5 Prozent.
So, SDK.
API-Docs.
MonkeySee.
Containers.
Arrays in MonkeySee.
Ja, okay, okay, okay.
Coding Conventions.
Das finde ich jetzt alles
nicht so spannend.
Core Topics.
Glances, Layouts.
Field.
Okay, was?
Ja, wie, wie, wie?
Na, was gucke ich denn da jetzt am besten?
API-Docs?
Hier, Simple.
Simple Data Field,
da haben wir es doch.
Simple Data Field.
Was jetzt?
Ist einfach ein Browser aufgegangen
hier von KS.
Einfach random.
Chat, wer von euch war das wieder?
Wer hat gerade random
meinen Explorer geöffnet?
Ja, Sauerei.
Okay, ja hier, guck mal.
Simple Data Field,
that displays current heart rate.
Return Info.
Specify the activity info
to display in the field hier.
Function Compute.
Ah, ich,
jetzt verstehe ich halbwegs,
wie das funktioniert.
Das ist ein bisschen wie,
das ist,
naja, okay, jetzt schwer zu sagen.
Es ist ein bisschen
wie ein Custom Windows Forms
Element.
So nach dem Motto
und dann da drin das machen
und Compute ist wahrscheinlich
einfach der Text, der zurückkommt.
Übrigens Format
funktioniert schon mal nicht richtig.
No Formatter for Monkey Sea.
Ja gut, das wundert mich jetzt
nicht wirklich.
Okay, 0.0 return.
Also sprich Info
Info
Heart Rate.
Ach, das ist ja nice, okay.
Da sieht man alles, was es gibt.
Dann returnen wir das doch mal.
Current Heart Rate.
Ich meine, die ist 0,
weil da ist sonst nix, aber okay.
So, dann schauen wir doch mal.
Jetzt machen wir Build.
Wenn wir Glück haben,
steht jetzt meine Heart Rate drin.
Was ich aktuell mache,
ein Custom Data Field
für Garmin Devices bauen.
Okay, da gibt es wahrscheinlich
einfach keine Daten aktuell.
Okay, Label können wir machen hier.
Heart Rate.
Ja, das ist,
ja, wobei es eigentlich egal.
Die Keg W Rate ist das.
So, Build.
Wenn es fertig ist,
dann mal Shift Ctrl F5.
Keg W Heart Rate.
Simulation.
Activity Data.
Wow, das macht einfach was.
Lab Timer.
Okay, wir haben die Simulation gestartet anscheinend.
Na gut,
das generiert einfach random Werte.
Es soll mir ja recht sein.
Random Werte, vollkommen okay.
Hast du ein Power Meter?
Nein.
Da bin ich am überlegen, wie ich das am besten mache.
Gibt es ja verschiedene Systeme.
Gibt es ja Kurbel Dinger
und komplette
komplette
so Sets.
Aber ich kann es ehrlich
erstmal ordentlich Fahrrad fahren
üben wieder.
So, das ist schon mal nice.
Das gefällt mir schon mal.
So, jetzt kann ich
jetzt können wir mal was ausprobieren.
Okay, also übrigens Leute,
ihr könnt alles ignorieren
außer
das da.
Man kann, man kann, glaube ich,
die Data Field Zielen drinnen nicht
nicht anpassen.
Kann das Layout ändern
und
jetzt ist es gecrashed.
Das war zu viel auf einmal.
Jetzt haben wir es kaputt gemacht.
Oh, was kann man da noch alles einstellen?
Time Units, Language, Connection Type.
Nein, gut, das ist jetzt nichts.
Wetter, Position, Sensors.
Du kannst echt ziemlich viel einstellen.
Ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Ganz cool.
So, wo war das mit Simulation?
Ja.
So, okay, wir lassen, wir lassen es einfach mal so,
dass das, das wird das ja ganz sinnig angezeigt.
Okay, also
jetzt, jetzt, jetzt testen wir
einfach mal ein bisschen was.
Also kann man, kann man den View
auf die, auf die Navigationsanzeige
umschalten?
Running, Sailing.
Das ist jetzt mir eigentlich ziemlich
egal.
Navigation Data, aber das,
das kann ich mir jetzt mal anzeigen
hier drin.
Das Go, nein, nein.
Das ist Monkey Sea.
Warum auch immer
kann man nicht.
Dann, dann lassen wir das mal so.
Okay, also jetzt, jetzt probieren wir das,
jetzt probieren wir das mal ein bisschen aus.
Also sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal,
ich würde gerne,
das ist richtig eklig.
Wobei, ich muss sagen,
es macht einen ganz brauchbaren Eindruck.
Anzeigen.
Wir stellen die Datafields doch nochmal um.
Hier, was hatten wir?
4a oder so?
Ne, 5a?
B?
Ich hatte doch sowas, wo das eine groß ist.
Ja, das da.
Ne, ja.
So, das, das, das obere.
Komm, wir machen eins.
Also eine Sache, ich würde gerne,
ne, ich muss das, ich muss, ich muss das mit Rand.
Ich muss es mit Rand anzeigen.
Lass mal mal, two fields, ja.
Also, von der Idee her,
ich will, dass der Rand,
oder zumindest irgendwas angezeigt wird,
wenn, also ich will, ich will die Zone anzeigen
von der Herz, von der, von der Heartrate.
Also sprich,
in, in, in,
das, was, das, was bei Garmin standardmäßig
grau, blau, grün,
oh,
mein Timer ist abgelaufen.
Grau, blau, grün, orange und rot ist.
Ja, Timer ist gut.
Und das, und das will ich,
das, das, das irgendwie mal anzeigen, so.
Also, der Typ ist ganz schön am,
ganz schön am strampeln mit 152 Puls.
Oder noch mehr.
So, wie kriege ich denn das jetzt raus?
Also, wie kriege ich, wie kriege ich Heartratezonen raus?
Zonen?
Okay.
HR, so, man hat leider keine Hilfe dafür.
Das wäre natürlich zu, zu easy.
Wie macht man denn eine Debug-Ausgabe?
Also, wie macht man denn eine Debug-Ausgabe?
Wie macht man eine Debug-Ausgabe?
HR Zone Biking zum Beispiel.
So, wir, wir, wir stellen, wir stellen die Activity mal ein.
Activity Select.
Wir machen jetzt, das ist ein Fahrradcomputer.
Wir machen
Bike,
oder, oder Cycling heißt das.
Cycling.
Was genau ist egal hier?
Name.
Genau, wie macht man hier eine Konsolen-Ausgabe?
Konsole?
Nein, System?
System, System ist immer gut.
System, Right,
Rightline?
Nein.
Output?
Konsole?
Nein, okay, ich muss nachgucken.
Print, Print könnte natürlich auch noch sein.
Print?
Ey, tatsächlich!
Printeln!
Output!
Ach hier!
Da ist es!
Da ist die Ausgabe!
Nice!
Der Karlsson, Dankeschön für den Sub!
Okay, das, das funktioniert.
Es sieht für mich so aus, als wird das einmal pro Sekunde gecallt.
Was im Endeffekt auch heißt,
man sollte hier drinnen keine Endlosschleife fabrizieren,
weil dann kann man das Device zum Hängen bringen.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren?
Four?
Each?
Wie macht man hier eine Schleife?
Monkey C, Loops.
Monkey C, Loop.
Wie sieht denn da eine Loop aus?
Loop.
While True, ja, hier.
Do, While.
While Loop, okay, dann machen wir das wirklich so.
While True,
falls das so geht.
Cack W.
Best, bester Output.
Build?
Hat, hat funktioniert.
Ist schon mal richtig.
Und jetzt, okay, Endlosschleife.
Jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's abkacken gleich.
Ja, oh!
Wow!
Oh, es ist gecrashed.
Crash, oh fuck!
Jetzt ist es komplett dead.
Okay, Endlosschleifen in Data Fields sind keine gute Idee.
Das habe ich, habe ich jetzt gelernt.
Generell sind so Locking,
so Locking-Sachen
auf Embedded-Systemen meistens keine allzu gute,
keine allzu gute Idee.
Das sind ja meistens ein Main-Thread
und vielleicht ein paar Background-Sachen,
aber die haben bestimmt nicht ein,
ein Thread für
für jedes Data Field.
Das wäre viel zu, viel zu krass dafür.
Simulator starten.
Data Field, wir hatten
5A.
Okay.
Und jetzt müssen wir noch starten
Activities, nee,
Cycling.
Ich, ich, ich, ich crashe es jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Äh, nee, wo, wo ging das jetzt nochmal?
Äh, was?
Okay.
Wo ging das jetzt nochmal mit den
Activity-Data?
Genau.
Okay.
Excellent.
Okay, also, Heart Rate,
Heart Rate Biking.
Das gebe ich, das gebe ich doch mal aus.
Mal gucken, was, was der mir da jetzt anzeigt.
Äh,
ist es gecrashed?
Error.
Ja, wie jetzt? Was jetzt?
Could not find Symbol.
Oder kann ich das bloß nicht printen?
Okay, das, das funzt, das funzt so nicht.
Funzt so nicht.
War Bloop gleich? Geht sowas?
Cannot find Symbol HR Zone
Sport Running.
Ja, ich, ich würde aber gerne meine
Frequenzzone wissen, weil anhand dessen kann ich dann
nen, nen, nen Balken drumherum malen
oder, oder auch nicht.
Ah.
API Level, ja, das haben wir.
Das sind wir.
Ach, Moment!
Das ist irgendein Enum.
Das ist nicht wirklich der
die Zone, sondern
okay, hier.
Get Heart Rate Zone.
Ist das, kann man da draufzugreifen?
Ach so!
Moment.
Jetzt, jetzt bin ich hochgradig, hochgradig verwirrt.
Wie, wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Get Heart Rate Zone.
So, und wir können da theoretisch für Bike
sagen wir zwei
und jetzt bilden wir das Ganze mal.
Cannot find Symbol. Get Heart on Time.
Äh.
Hä?
Warum, warum gibt's das nicht?
Wir haben doch, wir haben doch ne API Version,
die viel, viel neuer ist
wie, wie das hier.
Moment.
Vielleicht meckert er auch, wie ich das,
dass ich das falsch aufrufe.
Oh, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Haben die vielleicht, haben die vielleicht nen
Okay, das sollte aber gehen.
Get Current Sport.
Ups.
Äh, das sollte ja schon funktionieren.
Hä?
Muss ich irgendwas, muss ich irgendwas importen vielleicht?
Irgendwas
Modul. Toybox User Profile.
Ah.
Leute, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss irgendwas importieren.
Okay.
Import
Toybox
User Profile.
Aha.
Sister
Cannot find Symbol.
Okay.
Info as Activity Info.
Das, das ist, das ist ne Variable von dem.
Okay, das hat, das hat funktioniert.
Ah.
Muss ich das vielleicht so?
Okay.
User was born in year.
Das, das ist ein gutes, gutes Exempel.
System Out Brindeln.
Was?
Ah, die, die.
Die Docs sacken einfach.
Permission User Profile required for Toybox.
Oh.
Permission.
Edit Permissions.
User Profile.
Leute, ich rate das übrigens auch hier gerade nur ganz hart alles.
So, dass es jetzt irgendwie so wirkt, als wüsste ich, was ich mache.
Okay, es hat funktioniert.
Es hat kompiliert.
Reload.
Bin ich ja mal gespannt.
User was born in 1980.
Nice.
Profile.
Get Current Sport.
Kann man das jetzt so machen?
Error.
Hä? Alter.
Das ist ja super pp-ger.
Ja, gibt es.
Es gibt eine API, um.
Um die.
Nee, das nicht.
Es gibt eine API, um die.
Übersetzung anzuzeigen, zum Beispiel.
Also, das weiß ich nicht, ob das geht.
Eher nicht, oder?
Nee, das geht nicht.
Ich weiß, warum das nicht geht.
Weil die, die DI2 ist read only.
Die senden nur Daten.
Die können keine empfangen.
Ich muss sagen, jetzt bin ich ein bisschen planlos, warum er.
Mein API Level 1.0.
Wir sind auf API 4.2.
Das sollte ja nun wirklich mal.
Gar kein Problem sein.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass ich nicht alles.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass ich nicht alles importiert habe, was ich importieren muss.
Guck mal, man kann das auch einfach so ausgeben.
Cannot find symbol.
Das ist total weird Champ, Alter.
Das ist total weird Champ.
Okay, Profile.
Was kann man denn hier alles machen im Profile?
Ich sage mal, Leute.
Kann das sein, dass das überhaupt nicht context sensitiv ist?
Dass es einfach immer alles anzeigt?
Und deswegen cannot find symbol?
Das zeigt.
Okay, die Autocompletion ist kacke.
Die Autocompletion ist dumm.
Die zeigt einfach immer das gleiche an.
Für alles.
Ja, das ist dumm.
User, Profiles.
Du hast ja die Zeile schon.
Was soll ich hier gucken?
Profile, Activity Class.
Aber die haben doch hier auch drinnen stehen.
Das ist der Typ, den das zurückliefert, oder?
Okay, get current.
Hier.
Moment, was?
Okay, das ergibt ja gar keinen.
Ich meine, Profile get, Profile check ich noch.
Aber Profile get current sport.
What?
Ach, da ist sogar, guck mal, da ist sogar ein Beispiel.
Man ruft das auf dem User-Profile-Objekt auf.
Okay, HR, Sport, Bike.
Okay, das ist sehr, sehr merkwürdig, die Logik dahinter.
Aber es funktioniert.
Okay, Herzfrequenz.
Zone, Anzeigen in der Konsole, auf geht's.
Ja, Kunst.
Okay.
Alter, der will es aber wissen.
255 Herzfrequenz.
Deadge, würde ich sagen.
Aber gut, das ist ja nur zum Testen.
Okay, es ist ein bisschen weird, man muss sich dran gewöhnen.
Es ist ein bisschen weird, aber an sich nicht verkehrt.
Also, heißt im Endeffekt auch,
also, heißt im Endeffekt auch,
das heißt, gut, heißt, okay, guck mal,
dann sag mal, Zone beim Fahrradfahren,
also Herzfrequenzzone beim Fahrradfahren.
Jetzt ist die Frage, wie kann ich anhand der Zone hier was reinmalen?
Draw.
Draw Bitmap.
Draw Rectangle.
Draw Rectangle, das klingt auch gut.
Braucht man überhaupt?
Semikolons?
Okay, Draw Rectangle.
Von oben links
100,
100 Pixel.
Weiß auch immer, ob das Pixel sind, ich weiß nicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist das übrigens wieder, dass er findet er das jetzt nicht.
Ja, Error, Undefined.
Was?
Achso, nee.
Cannot find symbol, draw rectangle.
Ja, gut, Garmin.
Was das für eine Programmiersprache ist,
das ist
Monkey See,
weil Garmin der Meinung ist,
Monkey See.
Frag nicht.
DC Graphics.
Haben wir ein Beispiel dafür vielleicht?
Using Graphics.
Moment, using? Import?
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Okay, ist es jetzt using oder ist es
Monkey See using import?
Ich sag mal import.
Okay, could not draw.
Function on update.
Das muss ich aber doch bestimmt nicht im Data Field machen.
Mach ich das in der App?
Wie mal ich ein
Ja, geht.
Rectangle
Fatal, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Draw Hello World on the center of the screen.
Okay.
Using Toybox.
Using Toybox Graphics DC.
Das muss man on update machen.
Also nicht hier rein,
sondern ich weiß nicht, ob es hier rein muss.
On update.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
On build successfully.
Wait a minute, funktioniert das jetzt?
Nicht wirklich, ne?
Wo muss ich denn on update überhaupt reinpacken?
Und was ich sehr verwirrend finde,
warum ist es using?
Oder import?
Geht da vielleicht beides?
Ja, es geht beides.
Okay, das ist wir, wenn es das gleiche Keyword gibt.
Sehr gute Idee, ja.
Poolcam App für die Uhr.
Also das funktioniert so schon mal nicht.
Garmin on update.
Und Show on update.
Moment, das ist ja auch verkehrt.
Das muss ich bestimmt hier drin machen.
Ja, muss bestimmt hier rein.
Build successfully.
Okay.
Garmin data field on update.
Wir können ja mal testen, ob das überhaupt...
Hier.
On update.
Okay, man weiß nicht, was zuerst geladen wird.
Und vielleicht wird es überschrieben.
Und was passiert hier überhaupt?
View, find, draw, build by ID.
Ich würde vorschlagen, wir machen das mal anders.
Wir löschen das hier wieder.
Okay.
Wir gucken erstmal, ob das überhaupt aufgerufen wird.
Wir gucken mal, ob das überhaupt aufgerufen wird.
Hier, on update.
Dann sagen wir jetzt einfach...
System, printline, update.
Okay, so, build.
Build successfully, restart, output.
Kann man das, Leute, Visual Studio Kenner,
kann man das irgendwie so splitten, dass ich beides mir anzeigen lassen kann?
Den Build, Output und die Konsole?
Wie splitte ich denn das gescheit?
Habt ihr da eine Ahnung von, wie das funzt?
Ups, oje.
Habe ich zugemacht.
Okay, on update wird schon mal nicht aufgerufen.
On update juckt das nicht.
Es wird aufgerufen.
Current heart rate.
Okay, vielleicht ist watch UI simple data field nicht das Richtige,
sondern ich muss data field inheriten.
Error.
So, schon mal nicht.
Okay, guckt mal, man muss data field...
Ich copy paste mir mal kurz die Beispiel App hier.
Moment, jetzt geht natürlich die Main App nicht.
Wie hieß das vorher?
Data field view.
Und jetzt heißt es...
Ah, jetzt heißt es...
Moment, wie heißt der?
Okay.
Build.
Undefined symbol main layout.
Main layout.
Ist undefined.
Sehr nices Exempel.
Kann ich das einfach raus kommentieren?
Gucken, ob es jetzt läuft?
Shit, man.
Oh Gott.
Das funzt so schon mal nicht richtig.
Okay, kann ich wenigstens das alte wieder bilden?
Was? Undefined symbol detected?
Achso, ja.
Update.
Was über view?
Oder rechts oben am Tab-Rand?
Achso, das Terminal.
So, also simple on update.
Simple data field.
Ich...
Ich glaube,
das funktioniert mit einem simple data field nicht.
Wobei, direct known subclasses.
Das muss also auch in dem simple data field
funktionieren.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Mir fällt jetzt gerade nichts anderes ein, als
nochmal eine neue App zu erstellen.
Ach ne, das geht ja nur mit code.
Und einfach data field auszuwählen.
New project.
Five head.
Data field, complex data field.
Und nehmen wir wieder die aktuelle API.
Edge, okay.
Und das Ganze kommt hier rein.
Project 2, gut.
Das kann sich mal wieder verpissen.
So.
Sources, five head view.
On layout, compute, on update.
Hier haben wir jetzt eine on update.
Ja.
Also anscheinend muss man das wirklich im...
Muss das wirklich in ein normales data field?
Aber das ist doof, dass das nicht mit einem
mit einem simple data field geht.
Gut, wie auch immer.
Build.
Äh.
Habe ich da irgendwo aus Versehen eine 5 gerade
reingepastet oder so?
What?
Oh nein, der unterstützt five head nicht.
Die Dinger dürfen nicht mit 5,
die dürfen keine Zahlen drin haben.
Okay.
Five head heißt es dann jetzt halt.
Okay, build.
Build.
Okay, jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Run.
In dem Repo, hat er einen simple data field
in seinem Repo?
Das on update funktioniert?
Was für ein Window Manager, das ist i3.
Okay, das funktioniert schon mal.
Also, on update.
Ah, das haben wir vorhin nicht gemacht.
Daran lag es wahrscheinlich.
Wir haben nicht das parent,
wir haben nicht das parent on update gecallt.
Deswegen ist nichts passiert.
Okay, wir drawen jetzt eine rectangle.
Rekt.
Rektangle.
Wird jetzt gedraht.
Und zwar sagen wir jetzt mal hier.
Nicht, wie man das jetzt gescheit macht.
Draw.
Nee, wie geht das?
DC, draw, rectangle.
Ähm.
Moment, Leute.
Woher weiß der überhaupt?
Was ist denn value?
View find drawable by ID.
Value.
What?
Bildet das jetzt?
Okay, immerhin, es bildet.
Reload.
Mal gucken, ob wir jetzt einen rectangle in irgendeiner Art.
Ich muss ja die color noch irgendwie setzen.
Und? Rectangle?
Nein, kein rectangle da.
Sowas wie DC, set, color.
Okay.
Meine Güte, ey.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Graphics.
Da war doch eben irgendwo ein Beispiel.
Ja.
Black.
Ah, fill rectangle dann.
Okay, dann lassen wir den ganzen Shit mal weg und machen so wie im Beispiel.
Bild.
Okay, reload.
Moment, der fängt schon bei 100 an.
Wir wollen auch bei 0 anfangen.
Bei 0 und dann.
Ja, aber das scheint nicht zu funktionieren.
Ah.
Eine blue rectangle.
Nice.
Warum?
Warum wird das jetzt?
Angezeigt.
Okay, okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Das ist doch schon mal nicht schlecht.
So, und funzt.
Funzt das denn auch mit dem?
Simple data field.
Source?
Data field?
Moment, nee.
Moment.
Es wurde ja mit dem simple data field nie das update aufgerufen.
Nee, funktioniert nicht.
Wirbst du dich bei Garmin?
Ja, klar, ganz bestimmt.
Warum das rectangle nicht quadratisch ist?
Das ist wahrscheinlich, weil das schlicht und ergreifend abgeschnitten ist.
Weil das nicht so weit, weil das keine 100 Pixel hat.
Guck mal, probieren wir das mal aus.
Machen wir mal 20 mal 20.
Reloaden.
Run.
Guck, jetzt ist es quadratisch.
Das wurde einfach geklippt unten.
Was ist das für eine Sprache?
Das ist Monkey Sea.
Das ist irgendwas eigenes von Garmin.
Okay, also mal zurück zu der eigentlichen Sache, die ich ausprobieren wollte.
Wir wissen jetzt, wie wir farbige Rechtecke malen.
Okay.
Also, dann.
Warte mal, ich mache nochmal ein neues Visual Studio Code auf.
Und öffne hier mal das data field.
Da können wir uns das nämlich abgucken.
Heart rate.
Heart rate zone.
Okay, das gibt einen Array.
Das muss man, vorher muss man irgendwie using User Profile oder irgendwas.
User Profile.
Nein, das ist irgendein.
Unter der Haube macht der Java Zeug.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das eigentlich wirklich ist.
Five Head Background.
Finde ich ein guter Name.
Okay, so, jetzt haben wir die Heart Rate Zone.
Und wie haben die nochmal hier jetzt was?
Jetzt muss ich gerade mal checken.
Oh, ne, ich kann nicht mal weiter zurück.
No.
Wie haben die das mit Find Trouble?
Oh, nein.
Habe ich, habe ich.
Ach, weil ich es geschlossen habe.
Das ist ja doof.
Wie haben die das gemacht?
Find Trouble und dann irgendwie.
Weil von der Idee her.
Ich würde jetzt ja gerne nochmal einen Text malen.
So, das haben die doch irgendwie gemacht.
Irgendwie View Find Trouble by ID Value oder sowas in der Richtung.
Ich bin mir da nicht mehr sicher.
Irgendwie so lief das doch.
Ne.
Ach so, Permission, Permission.
User Profile.
Ah ja.
Nein.
Build Project.
Successful.
Nice.
Okay.
Find Trouble.
Da muss ich mir die Docs angucken.
Find Trouble by ID.
Find Trouble by ID, Timelabel, Set Text.
Nennen wir es mal.
Value, Set Text.
Keckel.
So, jetzt nochmal gucken, ob das jetzt funzt.
Error.
Set Text.
Nice.
Okay, ich copy-paste mir das mal.
Ob das jetzt besser funktioniert.
Ah ne, Timestring.
Set Text.
Okay, das Example suckt.
Wie sah das aus?
Okay, Chat.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal kurz bei mir im Stream.
Ins Wort.
Da hat man es ja eben gesehen.
Ja.
Ja, da war es doch.
Was habe ich hier für ein Projekt offen?
Datasys Simple Data Field.
Ja, da war es doch.
Find Trouble.
On Update.
Value, das habe ich doch.
Set Text.
Da war das doch gar nicht so.
Das ist ein Cast oder sowas.
Okay, ein bisschen weird-champ ist das schon.
Aber jetzt bildet das.
Ich musste doch noch irgendwas machen.
Jetzt muss ich noch sagen, View.
View on Update DC.
Update DC.
Warum man nicht sein Smartphone als Fahrradcomputer nimmt?
Naja, die offensichtlichste Sache ist Laufzeit.
Und Features.
Aber Laufzeit dürfte wahrscheinlich so das Argument sein, was jedem einleuchtet.
Mach mal drei Stunden Navigation mit ordentlicher Bildhelligkeit beim Smartphone.
Aha.
Okay, das ist schon mal dumm.
Das ist schon mal richtig dumm.
Wenn ich
nicht
nicht zeichnen
Moment, muss ich das vielleicht nacheinander machen?
Muss ich zuerst das updaten und dann hintendran die Rectangle malen?
Nur mal so.
Dass es auf die Reihenfolge ankommt?
Kann ja sein.
Ah.
Ah, nice.
Was warnt er mich denn hier?
Ach, ist not used.
Pff, mir doch egal.
System.
Brindeln.
Zone.
So, wie kriege ich das jetzt hin?
Also mein Ziel ist, dass meine Heartrate dasteht.
Das ist jetzt zum Testen.
Und hier unten ein Rectangle gemalt wird.
Mit der passenden Farbe.
Eigentlich, eigentlich will ich gar kein Rectangle.
Ich will eigentlich einmal drumherum
sowas malen.
Aber ich mein, wir können auch erstmal das
ne, hier oben mal einfärben dann.
Was ist das für ein Emulator?
Das was beim Garmin SDK dabei ist.
Also, heißt im Endeffekt auch
if
wie sieht denn das
mal reloaden
Chat, wie geht, wie funzt denn das jetzt nochmal?
Konnte man das hier irgendwie splitten oder so?
Das ging doch.
Man konnte doch irgendwie sagen
Ah.
Man konnte doch irgendwie sagen, dass man
das ist Panel.
Ich will nämlich beides anzeigen.
Das ist Monkey See.
Das ist so ein
so ein Garmin Ding.
Oh, Graphics Color Black.
Ne, Moment.
Ist das
ähm
Set Color.
Warum sind das zwei?
Vordergrund und Hintergrund oder
oder wie?
Hä?
Set Color, ah ja.
Foreground, Background.
Okay, Foreground, Background
White.
Color White.
Auf Garmin, Reload.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Wobei ich
das hier ja gar nicht brauche.
Das ist schon durchaus okay gewesen.
Background Color gibt es ja
Background Color gibt es ja in dem Fall nicht.
Wie machen die das hier?
Value
Value, Set Color
Black. Okay, also sagen wir hier
So, dass der Text
wenigstens auch gescheit aussieht.
Und jetzt können wir sagen, if
Sollen wir mal ausprobieren.
Ja, äh.
Sieht auch nicht besser aus.
Der Text sieht ziemlich, ziemlich
pp-iger, broken aus.
Mh.
Moment, das da oben ist ja nur das Label, oder?
Ich setze
Da steht ja gar nicht Keckel
Da steht My Value
Das ist ja auch verkehrt hier, oder?
Value, Set Text
Warum malten der nix?
Warum, hä?
Ich mach das doch genauso wie die das machen.
Ahmet, geh mal nicht auf den Keks.
Warum sagt
Warum setzt der denn das Value nicht?
Set Color
Muss man das jetzt verstehen?
Set Text
Er seht irgendwie den
Ach, guck mal hier
Find Trouble by ID as Text
Set Color
Aha, okay, das ist ja so
Okay, das ist ja wirklich übelst
Moment, was?
Ach, Background
Muss man das noch?
Alter, das muss mal einer checken.
Okay, was?
Background
Was haben sie sich da ausgedacht?
Ich steig da auch nicht so wirklich durch.
So, das ist ja im Prinzip das Kopieren
Set Background Color
Hehe
Get Background Color
So
Reload
Ob das jetzt irgendwas gebracht hat?
Hä?
Blö
Okay, wir machen mal
Color, Color, Color
Color Blue
Nicht Blau, Blue
Ob der irgendwas anzeigen kann?
Ah
Background
Ja, deswegen ist es dumm
Sowas mit Strings zu machen
Oh, Error, was?
No viable alternative
Was?
Alternative, was?
Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder das Problem, man?
Aber warte, ich hab's doch genauso gemacht
View, Find Trouble as Text
Set Color
Ach hier, da fehlt ein
Error, Alter
F*** mich schnell ab, man
Okay, es ist Graphics, Punkt Color
Build successful
Nice, so
Einfach funktionieren
Hehehe
Okay
Jetzt macht's gar nichts mehr
Geil
Moment, der Emulator ist abgekackt
Ach
Jetzt geht's auf einmal
Okay, Leute, ich check nix
Aber solange es funktioniert
Soll mir das Recht sein
Okay
Also
Dann, if
Jetzt können wir endlich mal ein bisschen Logik bauen
Also, if
Macht man überhaupt so ein if in dieser komischen Sprache?
Monkey see if
Language reference
If
Okay, ja, macht man
Also, if
Sound
Ich hoffe, Array-Syntax ist sowas hier in der Richtung
Also
So
Moment, wie
Wie hat man die Herzfrequenz ausgelesen?
Info
Current Heart Rate
Okay, Heart Rate
Wenn
Current Heart Rate
Kleiner gleich
Sagt, wenn ich Mist mache
Die erste Zahl ist
Dann
Gibt kein Pattern Matching, ja, das wird mich auch nicht
Achso
Also, wenn das die erste Zahl ist
Dann will ich Color
Machen wir einfach mal so
Die Default
Die Default Color ist einfach
Graphics Color
Gray
Oder Gray
Wie schreiben die das?
Gray
Oh, Leute, was habe ich da gesehen?
Triggered
Manche bestimmt schon
Gray
DK-Gray
LT-Gray
Light
Dark Gray
Vielleicht
War mal Light
Light-Gray
Dark-Gray
Okay, das ist
Das ist Default
Das brauchen wir nicht
Weil das Default mäßig Gray ist
Alles klar
Also
Wenn das kleiner ist
Als Heart Rate Zone 2
Dann wird Color
Color Blue
Yeah
So
Else if
Wenn Heart Rate
Kleiner
Als
Zone 2
Dann
Color Green
Und wenn Heart Rate
Kleiner
Zone
Kleiner gleich
Zone 3
Dann
Color Orange
So, das reicht jetzt erstmal
Zum Ausdruck
Und ansonsten
Else
Ah, ne
Muss ich
Muss ich schon mal mit
Elf
Else if
Machen wir mal
Den Default Fall
Habe ich hier oben schon
Äh, Moment
Ne
Ne, ne
Else
Schon okay
Else Rot
So
Color Red
Das da
Ähm
Gray
Okay
So
Äh, Zone 4 gibt es
Moment, achso
Es gibt ja noch mehr
Wart mal
0, 1, 2, 3, 4
Moment, es gibt
Ach, es gibt da noch 5
Ich dachte Garmin hat bloß
Achso, 5, ja
Ja, na gut
Passt doch
Danach gibt's
Else
Das ist der Else 2
Ja, das passt doch
Okay, Color
Dann
Hier
Hier die Color
Und für die
Und für die Rectangle
Die Color
Bild
Error
Was ist jetzt schon wieder das Problem
Info
Äh, was habe ich verkehrt gemacht?
Moment
Ah
Activity
Info
Das muss ich importieren, oder?
Tollbox, Activity
Okay
Äh
Ne, ist doch
Ist doch
Was ist das Problem?
Moment
Muss ich sagen
Activity Info
Muss ich das so machen?
Ach, man
Garmin
SDK
Ah, okay
Aha
Activity
Get
Activity Info
Ist es in dem Fall
Da musst du erstmal drauf kommen
Okay, hat funktioniert
Was?
Äh, was genau
Ist jetzt das Problem?
Okay, wir müssen eine Runde
Printline Debugging machen
System
Print
Heart Rate
Und System Print Zone
Oh, man
Alter
Vielleicht kann Heart Rate nicht ausgelesen werden
Das könnte natürlich sein
Und dass er deswegen
Dass er Permissions für Activities braucht
Könnte das sein?
Dass er keine
Dass er keine Permissions hat für Activities
Das ist 0
Die Heart Rate ist 0
Okay
Permissions
Äh
Sensor vielleicht
Lass uns mal gucken
Was hat das Ding hier für Permissions
Permissions
Ne, das war auch nur
S-Numeric
Orderation
Or String
Okay
Activity Info
Funktioniert schon mal nicht
Ach so
Vielleicht ist die Heart Rate
Simulation nicht an
Ja, das wird es wahrscheinlich sein
Simulation
Äh, wo war das jetzt?
Ah
Das war das Problem
Das war nicht an
Okay
Das müssen wir aber auf jeden Fall bedenken
Das müssen wir auf jeden Fall bedenken
Was das 0 sein kann
Weil dann
Funktioniert es nicht
Wo stand hier was?
Heart Rate works fine
Steht da
First
To get
You want to check
Äh
Ähm
Aber die Farbe stimmt nicht
Oder vielleicht stimmt die Farbe ja doch
Okay
Wir müssen das erstmal checken
Ob das 0 ist
If
Ganz einfach
HR
Ich hoffe das macht man so
Then
Return
Nein
Das macht man nicht so
Doch
Das macht man so
Zeile 77
Was denn?
Okay
System
String
Line
The heart rate
Das ich weiß was abgeht
Und jetzt sagen wir
Run
Without debugging
Ja
Was ist da?
Ah Moment
Ich hab doppelt
If hier stehen
Wait a minute
Ja
Aber es ergibt trotzdem
Keinen Sinn
Warum das
Ja doch
Is blue
Ne Moment
Is
Is unterhalb von Zone
Von Zone 1
Okay dann müsste es
Dann müsste es
Gray sein
Okay das war
Das war der Bug
Okay alles gut
Restart
So jetzt
Jaja
So der Typ
Der muss mal ein bisschen
Ein bisschen schaffen hier
Ein bisschen anstrengen
Ja
Funktioniert
So der müsste jetzt mal
Ein bisschen höhere
Herzfrequenz bekommen
Das ist jetzt
Aber 153
Wird er so schnell nicht kriegen
Zumindest
Zum testen
Müsste der mal
Ein bisschen höhere
Herzfrequenz bekommen
Der Dude
Äh was
Zum
Bin ich hier gelandet
Ich wollte
Wupp Wupp
Wieder anmachen
Ah guck mal
Jetzt wird es
Jetzt wird es blau
Okay sehr schön
Das funktioniert ja
Das ist im Prinzip
Genau das was
Ich hab mir vorgestellt
Genau das was ich haben will
Also ich will jetzt
Nicht wirklich die Zahl
Hier anzeigen
Aber ich will
Ne Rectangle malen
Anhand der
Jeweiligen
Herzfrequenz
Ne das ist gut
Jetzt hat er 151
Moment 151
Ist immer noch
Hier drunter
Der hat ziemlich
Krasse Herzfrequenz
Zonen
Der Demo Typ
Okay jetzt
Können wir mal
Die Rectangle
An irgendeiner sinnvollen
Stelle positionieren
Ich würde
Ich würde ja gerne
Ehrlich gesagt
Einfach nur
Ne Streifen malen
Ich würde ja am liebsten
Ne Streifen
Ich will ja
Ich will ja nicht einfach
Da oben sowas
Ne Streifen
Ja ne Streifen
Sollte ja reichen
Also mal
Fill Rectangle
Am besten
Unten
Unten oder oben
Oben ist halt
Am einfachste
Ach guck mal
Jetzt wird es grün
Es funktioniert alles
Okay nice
Also am besten
Am besten wäre natürlich
Wenn er
Unten oben
Links rechts
Keine Ahnung wo da das beste ist
Wir machen es oben
Oben dürfte es am einfachsten sein
Ein grüner Strich
Okay was ist was
Fill Rectangle
Ist
Referenz
Von
Ja
Breite
Höhe
Okay also
4 Pixel
Breite
Es wäre cool
Wenn man irgendwie
Relative Einheiten
Machen könnte
Aber kann man anscheinend nicht
Okay
4 Pixel
Höhe
Und irgendwie
Keine Ahnung
2000 Pixel
Breite
Das sollte glaube ich
Reichen
Das wird dann zwar abgeschnitten
Aber das macht ja nichts
Das will ich ja
Ja
Sehr schön
Jetzt wird
Jetzt wird oben
In dem jeweiligen
Data Field
Eine Linie angezeigt
Mit
Die die
Herzfrequenz
Symbolisiert
Das ist
Ich brauche ja gar kein
Gar kein Label
Wo das angezeigt
Wird
Sondern je nachdem
Wenn sich
Wenn sich das ändert
Ja
Machen wir nochmal
Andere Herzfrequenz
Ja genau
Dann wird das
Blau oder grau
Oder sonst was
Das finde ich
Eigentlich gar nicht
So schlecht
Weil ich will ja
Ich will ja ein bisschen
Mehr Werte
Anzeigen können
Und die Pulsfrequenz
Die brauche ich nicht
Unbedingt direkt
Als Strich
Und jetzt müssen wir das
Irgendwie
Layout mäßig
So machen
Dass ich 3
Da müssen wir uns
Layouts angucken
Dass ich quasi
Das hier 3fach
Gleichmäßig
Unter
Unterteilt bekomme
Da müssen wir mal
In den Guide
Gucken
Layout
Set
Main
Layout
Was
Was passiert
Hier
On
Layout
Compute
On
Layout
Set
Top left
Layout
Was
Top right
So we will use
The top right
Layout
Ah
Moment
Ne ne ne
Das ist nicht
Mein Layout
Das ist
Ich kann
Mein
Das anpassen
Je nachdem
Was der Typ
Was der User
Für Layouts
Ausgewählt hat
Das sind die
Default Garmin Farben
Ja aber da muss ich
Das selbst ausrechnen
Das ist doch blöd
Das wäre doch viel besser
Wenn es was Fertiges gibt
Äh aktuell
Aktuell interessiert sich
Säge
Ah das ist jetzt
Erstmal nicht so
Nicht so wild
Ich will
Ein Layout
Haben
Innerhalb von
Meinem Datafield
Ich will
Ich will quasi
So eine Art
Grid
Haben
Falls es sowas gibt
Gibt es ein
Grid
Max wie war
Wo war das
Demorepo
Das geht
Bestimmt
Das geht bestimmt
Man muss nur wissen
Nach was man sucht
Also Layout
Ist auf jeden Fall
Schonmal falsch
Irgendwas mit Box
Vielleicht
Bounding
Box
Checkbox
Menü
Datafield
Alter hier
On Update
Clear Clip
Was auch immer
Clear
Was da geklippt
Wird
Ey der Typ
Hat ja richtig krass
Viele Beispiele
Aber wie man
Wie man da irgendwelche
Trouble
Layouts macht
Auch nicht
Ich meine natürlich
Kann ich das
Kann ich das selbst
Irgendwie ausrechnen
So
Device Breite
Durch 3
Oder sowas
Ok
Wie kriege ich
Wie kriege ich die
Breite
Von dem Device
Raus
Get Text
Get Width
Ok
Ja
DC
Get Width
Gucken wir uns
Das mal an
DC
Schauen wir mal
Was das
Was das sagt
Was das ausgibt
Achso
Das da
So
Also
Da könnte ich
Natürlich schon sagen
Bar
Width
Man könnte
Das quasi
Durch 3 teilen
Wenn ich
3 Sachen
Anzeigen
Möchte
Ja
Und dann
Dann hat man
Sel
Width
Oder sowas
Und dann
Habe ich
Wo die
Begrenzung
Ist
Das Erste
Ist 0
Bis
Das Nächste
Ist
Ja
Das
Plus
Und beim
Nächsten
Schluss
Bei
Breite
Minus
Ja
Das könnte
Man machen
Da könnte
Man quasi
Anhand
Dessen
Ausrechnen
Wo man
Was hin
Ja
Das funktioniert aber
So schon mal
Nicht
Weil der hier
Irgendwelche festen
Labels
Setzt
Das ist halt
Sack
Ne
Wo hier
Wo setzt
Überhaupt hier
Die Sache
Mit dem
Ach hier
Value
View Value
Wo hat
Dann das
Überhaupt her
Kann es sein
Das ist schlicht
Und ergreifend
Jedes
Data
Field
Was man da selbst
Einfügen muss
Wahrscheinlich
Es gibt wahrscheinlich
Wahrscheinlich hat
Jedes Data
Field
Einmal
Label
Und einmal
Text
Das das das doofe
Ist
Das kann ich jetzt
Ja gar nicht
Verwenden
Wobei doch
Guck mal
Ich kann
Aber
Ich brauch
Ich brauch ja
Mehrere
Values
Das funktioniert schon
Mal
Ich glaube
Ich muss das
C U
M Value
Benutzt das doch
Irgendwo was
Kann man hier
Irgendwas machen
Was gibt es denn
Moment
Guck mal
Data
Field
Data Field
Es geht ja aktuell
Aufs Display
Was hat denn das
Für
Für Methoden
Dude Master
Dankeschön
Für den Sub
Compute
Create
Field
Aha
Create
A new
Custom
Fit
Field
Okay
Ich
Ich probiere das jetzt
Einfach mal aus
Data Field
Create
Field
Name
Ah
Hier kann ich
Okay
Name
Blob
Field
ID
Ja
Keine Ahnung
Zwei
Type
Man weiß es nicht
Create
Field
Unique
Identifier
Okay
Komm
Ist bestimmt
Wir machen mal
Data Type
String
Und Options
Gibt es noch was
Count
Message Type
Es ist Optional
Optional
Kommt weg
Ähm
Error
No
Viable
Alternative
Add
Input
Data Field
Create
Okay
Es ist Optional
Aber ich muss trotzdem
Irgendwas eingeben
Also
Äh
Null
Wenn es Optional ist
Eins
Hä?
Alter
Das ist
Das wird zu Six Head
Alter
Der Kram
Garmin
Haben wir da nicht irgendwie
Ein Beispiel
Hat der Typ
In GitHub
Hier in diesem GitHub
Repo
Ich bin so
Keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert
What
The
Permission
Fit
Contributor
Ich
Bin mir nicht sicher
Ob das wirklich
Das ist was ich haben will
Moment
Das ist ein Data Field
Für Garmin Connect
Das ist was
Ganz was anderes
Das ist
Moment
Das ist für die Zusammenarbeit
Mit der Mobile App
Nee
Das ist
Das ist gar nicht
Das was ich haben will
Okay
Das ist
Das ist falsch
Also
Die Docs
Sind auch nicht
So
Aussagekräftig
Create a new
Fit Field
Äh
Field
Records
Custom
To a fit
File on a device
Okay
Das ist auf jeden Fall
Nicht das was ich haben will
Das ist
PPGard
Nein nein nein
Das brauchen wir nicht
Okay
Dann zurück
Zum eigentlichen Plan
Das da kommt
Alles weg
So
Und im Endeffekt
Was ist denn hier
Warum ist das
Rot
Weil
Der das nicht
Gecheckt hat
So
Ähm
Heißt
Im Endeffekt
Ich muss das wirklich
Selbst berechnen
Das heißt
Ich kann mir das hier
Komplett sparen
Und muss das alles
Selbst malen
Short Text
Dachte ich mir
Dass das so ist
So
Okay
Das ist jetzt natürlich
Was wo ich
Gar keinen Plan habe
Wie man das gescheit macht
Okay
Oben
An der linken Ecke
Nee
An 5
An 6 da
Im Moment
Links
Von oben
So
Font
Ja
Aber die haben hier bestimmt
Ein Beispiel für
Nö
Natürlich nicht
Font
Graphics
Font Type
The font to use
Graphics
Font
Äh
Fonts
Oh no
Gibt es da nicht
Da gibt es
Da muss es doch schon
Irgendwie ne default
Font geben oder
Hier
Font small
Font large
Font medium
Ich hoffe das tut so
Okay
Text
Blub
Justification
Graphics
Text
Justify
Äh
Left
Das funktioniert doch jetzt
Im Leben so nicht
Der meckert doch wieder rum
Dass ich irgendwas
Verkehrt gemacht habe
Und
Error
Cannot find symbol
Fonts
Vielleicht ist es einfach
Fonts medium
Graphics
Hey
Es hat funktioniert
Bam
Vielleicht sollte ich noch
Die color
Vielleicht mal ändern
So
Nee
Es hat funktioniert
Leute
Er hat
Blub
Gedraht
So wir sollten
Das hier noch ändern
Color
Black
Graphics
Color
So
Ja
Nice
Das funktioniert
Wir lassen es vielleicht
Noch
Lass es mal noch
Ein bisschen weiter unten anfangen
Das sieht sonst
Ziemlich beschissen aus
Das hängt so
An dem Strich dran
Ja
Sieht gar nicht
Mal so übel aus
Oder
Mein Ars läuft
So
Rectangle
Malen wir jetzt
Ne neue
Wir müssen
Wir müssen das jetzt
Aufsplitten
Das Ding
In 3
Unter
Unterfelder
Also
Wir malen den Text
Jetzt malen wir
Von links
Ab
Ab 10
Sagen wir mal
Ja
Höhe
Polle
Und
Breite
Machen wir mal
Sollte
Reichen
Moment
Nee
Nicht
X
Hier
Sel
With
Da
Will ich
So
Stelle. Das müssen wir jetzt ausrechnen. Das müssen wir jetzt ausrechnen. Also, Chatgilder,
müsst ihr mir mal mit eurem 5-Header-Chat-Schwarmintelligenz helfen. Wie rechnen wir
jetzt die passende Position aus? Also, das hier bleibt immer gleich. Die vertikale Zentrierung,
das ist easy. Das können wir so lassen. Aber das hier ist tatsächlich ein bisschen komplizierter.
Also, es ist Cellwidth mal i, oder? Also das erste ist dann halt 0 durch 2 ist 0. Das ist
nicht so ganz richtig. Aber wir können ja mal prinzipiell gucken, ob es dann für die
anderen funktionieren würde. Beim ersten hat er wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Probleme.
Äh, nee. PPGa, 5-Heads, low IQ-Time, Leute, was ist hier verkehrt? Ach so, Moment, ich weiß,
was verkehrt ist. Wir machen i gleich 1. Values minus 1. Mir fällt grad nix anderes ein. Jetzt
müsste es doch passen, oder? Das G1 sei dann die Hälfte von... Pass auf, pass auf, und, und...
Nee. Okay, da bin ich eindeutig zu dumm jetzt grad für. Das erste stimmt. Ah, ich weiß,
was das Problem ist. Plus... Ah, plus... Das muss nicht mal Cellwidth, es muss mal Cellwidth
plus Cellwidth sein, oder? Oh man, jetzt, jetzt bin ich nicht mehr durch. So? Ich hasse solche
Sachen, man. Ja! Nee. Oh, wie ich solche Alignment-Sachen hasse, ey, da dreh ich immer
durch bei. Kennt ihr Chasm Workspaces? I wieder ein 0? Okay, try an error type. Nee, ich glaub,
meine Logik ist noch nicht so ganz ausgereift. Das durch 2 ist das Problem. Warte mal. Ja,
tatsächlich. Das durch 2 ist... Okay, ja, ja, ja, ja, Moment, es ist immer, Moment,
es ist immer Cellwidth durch 2. Nee, Moment, Leute, es ist immer Cellwidth durch 2. Weil
die Dinger sind immer gleich breit, und ich möchte es immer... Cellwidth durch 2 ist immer
die Mitte. Ja, also, also das hier für sich genommen ist schon mal richtig. Das hier ist
immer die Mitte minus der Text. Allerdings ist nur die Frage, woran fängt. Und eigentlich müsste
es wahrscheinlich... Ja, müsste Cellwidth dann pro Schleifen-Durchlauf 1 hochgehen. Das passt
jetzt noch nicht genau, aber sollte für 1 und 2 passen. Ja, das ist schon mal gut. Das ist schon
mal gut. Und jetzt mal i. Das funktioniert beim ersten nicht, aber danach. Jetzt haben wir es
irgendwie zerstört. Okay, einmal ordentlich drüber nachgedacht und schon funktioniert es. Das finde
ich sehr gut. Exzellent ist das. Exzellent, exquisite, excellent, 5 hat time. Ja, das ist
doch schon mal nice, oder? Jetzt muss ich... Morgen muss ich mir angucken, wie ich das sideloaded
bekomme auf meinen Fahrradcomputer. Da kannst du bestimmt per USB anschließen das Ding und drauf
sideloaden ohne Connect IQ Store oder sonst was. Das finde ich sehr, sehr nice. Natürlich ist hier
gerade nichts dynamisch dran. Das ist ja klar. Tatsächliche Werte anzeigen. Ja, können wir
machen. Also nehmen wir mal beispielsweise hier die Steigung, die man gerade unterwegs ist. Wie
weiß ich gar nicht, wie man das rauskriegt. Ja, oder Elevation. Wie schreibt man Elevation?
Methods, Elevation, Great. Da ist halt die Frage, wie man das auswertet. Get Elevation History. Ne,
das will ich nicht. Ich will eigentlich Sensor. Hier, Sensor. Was haben wir denn da? Sensor Info.
Ne, Altitude müsste es dann schon sein. Altitude. Okay. Also, sofern ich diese Garmin Dinger irgendwie
gecheckt habe, dann müsste es quasi sowas sein wie, ja, sowas wie Sensor. Ne, Get. Bin ich verwirrt.
Was? Sensor Info. Und Sensor, what? Okay, Sensor Get Info ist es dann. Get Info. Also, wenn ich die
Garmin Sachen irgendwie halbwegs gecheckt habe. Sensor Get Info und jetzt Altitude. Wahrscheinlich
brauche ich noch Permissions dafür. Ja, Permission Sensor. Ja, dachte ich mir. Sensor. Ja, Save.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Build. Successful. Jawohl. Reload. Guck mal, vielleicht reicht das ja schon.
Oh no. Get Info not available to data fields. Okay. Dann muss man das irgendwie anders auswählen.
Ich meine, die echten Werte anzeigen ist ja nur noch eine Formsache, in dem man rausbekommt,
wo man die herkriegt. Also anscheinend geht das so in einem Data Field schon mal nicht. Wie kriegt
man sonst noch die Höhe? Activity Info. Ja, das ist doch gut. Die haben wir doch schon. Die haben
wir doch schon. Activity Info. Ja, dann machen wir das mal anders hier. Activity Info. Heart Rate.
Current Heart Rate. Machen wir das da weg. Alt. So, genau. Und jetzt, wenn ich hier irgendwo was
vergessen habe. Nein, Build successful. Jetzt sollte das funktionieren. Insofern er nicht
wieder irgendwas zu meckern hat. Gucken wir mal, ob er abkackt oder nicht. Im Moment habe ich noch
Get Info irgendwo drin. Ach, fast. By the way, warum bricht immer das Run ab? Oder nicht immer,
manchmal. So, Prager, Prager. Was? Expected String given Float. Okay. Wie caste ich einen Float zu
einem String? S-String? Fragezeichen? Okay, anscheinend ja. Das geht aber wahrscheinlich
so netter. Und? Expected String given Float. Wie jetzt? Das ist Monkey Seed. Das ist irgendwas
eigenes von Garmin. Okay, Garmin SDK. Float to String. Float to String. Moment. Float. Format.
Prozent. Okay. Format. Prozent. Prozent D? Vielleicht? Ja, ja, ja, ja. Okay. Nein,
to String wäre zu naheliegend. Was? Moment. So nicht. Run. Ja. Wir sind auf 1071 Meter,
Leute. Falls ihr das noch nicht wusstet. Das ist nice. Also, Chat, was sagt ihr? Für die
allerersten Gehversuche mit dem Garmin SDK gar nicht mal schlecht. Und ich muss sagen,
ich finde, die haben das nicht schlecht gemacht. Also, man kommt damit wirklich gut klar. Die
haben einen halbwegs brauchbaren Emulator. Die Sprache ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt
mein Favorit. Aber geht irgendwie auch noch ganz gut klar. Oh, das können wir alles löschen. Das
werden wir eh nicht verwenden. Also, ich dachte auch nicht, dass wir das alles so heute hinkriegen.
Vollkommen fein, oder? Mit C++ wäre das deutlich ätzender gewesen. So viel kann ich schon mal
sagen. Ja, die Dokumente sind nicht so geil, aber immerhin. Ich meine, man kommt halbwegs durch.
Ich denke, das kann man so lassen. Ich werde das mal morgen just for fun sideloaden auf
mein Fahrradcomputer. Vielleicht machen wir das auch im Stream. Und dann gucken wir das uns mal
mit echten Werten an. Allerdings ohne, dass ich meine GPS Position leake. Aber schon mal praktisch.
Gefällt mir echt gut. Jetzt müssen wir nur noch gucken. Das machen wir aber nicht heute. Unit.
Unit. Distance Unit. Weil dieses Kilometer pro Stunde. Was ist denn eine Complication? Kann mir
das irgendjemand erklären? Subscribe and publish to Complication. Weil man braucht ja Garantie.
Also es muss irgendwo den Unit Text und so zum Malen geben. Das kann nicht sein,
dass man das selbst machen muss. Also ein Widget. Okay. Weil guckt, wie das hier Garmin malt. Die
schreiben hier KMH so. Und das gibt es doch garantiert schon fertig. Als so irgendwie
Drawable. Da muss man mal gucken hier. Text. Da kann man garantiert irgendeine Unit direkt
Drawen lassen. Das muss bestimmt nicht jeder Datafield Entwickler. Denn eigene,
eigene Einheiten malen. Gibt es bestimmt schon irgendwas Fertiges. Okay. Schön,
dass ihr dabei wart. Reicht für heute. Wir haben wirklich was auf die Reihe gekriegt. Ich bin
begeistert. Das ging wirklich ernsthaft jetzt deutlich angenehmer, als ich mir das gedacht
habe. Guck mal, sogar die Pulsanzeige funktioniert. Ich werde jetzt pennen gehen. Bedgetime. Boomer
müde. Boomer schlafen. Bis die Tage, Leute. Macht's gut. Bis dann. CU. Ja,
mal wieder endlich endlich mal Broggers Bastelstream. Bis dann. Macht's gut. CU.